[APPLAUSE]
JACK COOKE: Thanks.
And first thing I have to say
is I used your toilets on my way
in.
And to be advertised on the
back of a toilet door, that
is a life achievement.
That is great.
I'm so proud of that.
So thank you,
whoever put that up.
Yeah, so today, I want to talk
to you about climbing trees.
Some of you might never
have done it or some of you
might not have done it
since your childhood.
And I want to try and persuade
as many of you as possible
to give it another go.
I've written a book, "The
Tree Climber's Guide,"
which basically explore my
favorite trees around London.
It's not specific
to London in that
the sort of general
chapters and philosophy
are, say, climb a
tree wherever you are.
But definitely the dynamic
between living in a city
and feeling a bit of stress
by never having access
to nature and the trees is
where it all stems from.
I have to say Google
has been invaluable
because I've used your
satellites to hunt down
trees across the city.
And I always get very excited
using Google satellite
and seeing a shadow cast by
a tall tree and thinking,
I've got to go there and see
if that's a good climbing tree.
Before I begin, there's a quite
important thing I should say.
This book is for amateurs.
It says "The Tree
Climber's Guide,"
but I am in no way a
professional climber,
alpinist, mountaineer.
You don't need any special skill
or strength to climb trees.
You can start low till
your confidence builds
and explore trees
at your own pace.
I think increasingly, we
try and sort of quantify
exercise that we do.
You know, we've got to have
the right gear and gadgets
when we go jogging or
cycling or anything else.
And for me, climbing trees
is the complete antithesis
of that.
It's just a free
adventure for everyone.
It's easy to do.
Don't go and get
yourself strapped
into a harness with a helmet
and some angry instructor.
Just go and find a nice,
easy tree in your local park.
It's a lot more fun.
We're all instinctive
climbers, really.
I mean, as we know, we
share DNA with the apes
and a common ancestor.
So our deep history,
we're all climbers.
And I was reading this
theory this morning,
which fascinated
me, about-- you know
when you go to sleep at night?
And everyone does this.
And suddenly, you're
sort of drifting off,
and then you jerk because you
kind of roll over in the bed.
Well, the theory-- I don't
know if it's apocryphal--
that I was reading this
morning saying that actually
stems from when we
lived in the trees.
So it was like a
knee-jerk reaction
to falling off a branch in
the middle of the night.
So I quite like that.
Anyway, I hope you can
all-- can everyone see this?
This is my favorite
London planetree.
They're called London
planes because they're
a cross of two different species
of planetree, one from America,
one from the Far East.
Actually, that's rubbish--
from the Near East.
It's kind of Turkey, Sicily
is where it's all from.
This one is about five minutes
from London's biggest building
site.
So the Battersea Park
power station development.
And it's all going on there.
So it's one of my favorites.
And I think what it illustrates,
if you look at this--
and I don't know
how many of you,
if you just looked at
this out of context,
would have thought that's
right in the middle of London.
I mean, it's the best escape.
And escape is very much at
the heart of climbing trees.
So yeah, we'll start with that.
Climbing trees is also
an-- that's not in London.
Climbing trees is also an
amazing way of exploring.
How many of you climbed
trees as children?
Show of hands.
How many of you climbed
trees in the last five years?
Excellent.
A hardcore here of
committed climbers.
You know, I don't think
there's any reason why
adults shouldn't enjoy climbing
trees as much as children.
When you see-- if you
go into a London park,
you often see toddlers
swarming around trees
and reaching up for branches,
again, kind of instinctively.
You very rarely see an adult
in a tree, and if you do,
it's often a little
bit suspicious.
You're like, what are
they doing up there?
But I think children have the
best possible relationship
to the natural
world because it's
so unfettered with any
kind of assumptions.
And by climbing
trees, I really feel
like I've got back to that.
You know, before
I wrote this book,
I had a very limited knowledge
of different tree species.
But when you're focusing on
not falling out of a tree
and killing yourself,
you take in all
of the microscopic details
of different trees you climb.
So now I feel like a much more
competent amateur naturalist,
just through spending
time exploring the trees.
So another amazing thing
about climbing trees
in London-- or any
city, for that matter--
is the fresh
perspective it gives you
on streets you've walk
down hundreds of times,
very familiar places.
So this is in a cedar
tree in Greenwich Park.
And it's not
filtered or anything.
It was a sort of misty day.
But looking back on the
Docklands-- you know,
I'm only a few stops out of the
heart of the financial heart
of London.
But again, you could be
in the middle of nowhere.
And I think getting those
kind of views from a treetop,
it's just a very fresh outlook.
You come back down to the
ground, go back to work.
You know, you climb a tree on
your lunch break around here.
And you come back, and you
just feel sort of revitalized.
So it's another nice side of it.
The thing with
trees in the cities,
though, is that people are
very fond of pruning them.
All the lower
branches tend to get
lopped off when councils and
park authorities and things--
they don't want to be
sued for you stubbing
your toe by climbing a tree.
So they tend to limb them
up, is the expression.
So often, you find
trees like this.
This is a zelkova tree in
Hyde Park, which is actually
a kind of elm-- not the ones
that died off in Britain,
but a different Caucasian elm.
And passing a tree like that, if
you're addicted to it as I am,
you see it and think, I've got
to get into that because it's
just got this amazing kind of
maze of branches higher up.
But how do you do it?
Best thing-- take a friend.
So this is a very cynical
"Times" journalist
I forced into a beech tree.
But the great thing about him
is he's at least 6 foot 3".
So I'm only 5 foot 7".
But take a tall friend
with you tree-climbing,
and you suddenly open up
this enormous capacity
to get into trees.
Or, you know, you come up
to this trunk and think,
there's no way I
can get up that.
But with the help of Jack or
another Jack, it's very easy.
I think the other
thing this illustrates
is if you do start climbing
trees again and enjoying
it and doing more
and more, don't just,
like an adrenaline
junkie, rush up a tree
and come straight
back to the bottom
and go about your business.
Spend some time in the branches.
Nothing like having a
cup of coffee in a tree,
as we're doing,
shooting the breeze
and setting the world to rights.
It's a wonderful space, I
think, particularly in summer.
Obviously, deciduous
tree, so it's not in leaf
when we did this.
But it's sort of like
having your own summer
house above London.
And it's a great space to take
time out and to really think
and-- you know, take some
work up there if you want to.
I mean, it's available.
The other thing, I think, is
that a big problem for people
that are going back
to climbing trees
after having not done it
for a long time is fear.
As children, we tend to have
a slightly more devil-may-care
attitude to doing
things like this.
And as you grow up, you
kind of-- just stepping up
on the kitchen sideboard
is scary from a vertigo
perspective.
So again, I'd say
start on mature trees.
This is a hornbeam in Glasglow.
And this branch,
they're actually
called ironwood because of
the density of the wood.
But you look at that,
there's no way--
it doesn't matter
if you're 25 stone,
you're not going to
break that branch.
It's an awesome tree.
And there's lots of
trees around London
with low branches
like that you can just
spend some time getting used
to climbing again, swing about
on it, and then you can
progress and climb higher.
People watching--
I mean, it's great.
Honestly, I'm not a peeping Tom.
But going up trees and
watching the world go by
is one of the best things.
This is a swamp cypress
in St. James Park,
right next to Buckingham Palace.
And you can climb about
60 foot above the city
because it's just
a natural ladder.
It's got branches
every two feet.
I was a bit worried I was going
to get snipered by someone
on the Buckingham Palace roof.
But actually, I
think I might just
read you the extract
from the book on this one
because it's a fun tree.
"The royal perch, St.
James Park, swamp cypress.
If, like me, your chances
of taking tea with the queen
are slim, you can indulge in the
next best thing-- an audience
with Buckingham Palace from
the summit of neighboring St.
James's Park.
At the park's west end,
facing the wedding cake
of the royal residence,
stand two giant trees.
Imports from America's deep
south, these twin swamp
cypresses have been drinking
London lake water for 90 years.
Of the two, the tree to
the south of the lake
provides the easier ascent.
Making my way across
the blue bridge,
I nimbly dodge trains of
tourists force-feeding ducks.
Once on the south side,
I follow the water west
towards the palace.
The swamp cypress
is hard to miss,
standing head and shoulders
above its neighboring
trees, straight-backed
as a palace guard.
The climber is
rarely conspicuous,
but to avoid an audience, I
carefully time my approach.
The lowest branch is
within easy reach.
Once I've gained this and
climbed a little higher,
I am hidden from
the crowds and pause
to admire the strange pink hue
of the tree in which I sit.
The bark on the trunk
has a stringy texture,
smoothing in places to
a paper consistency.
Looking up, I see a rosy
stairway spiraling above me
for 70 feet, the branches
closely spaced with plentiful
holds.
The thicker arms
grow in a helix.
Ascending, I follow
these around the trunk
as if climbing a church tower.
Before long, I'm well above
the ice-cream crowds, peepholes
in the summer foliage revealing
a network of paths below.
At the tree's
peak, four branches
fan out like the twisted
prongs of a fork.
Sitting at their
junction, I have
a comfortable saddle for my
legs and a strong support
for my back.
To the south, the tiny
capsules of the London Eye
can be seen
revolving in silence.
In front and far
below, the toy soldiers
of Buckingham Palace
parade between pill boxes
and Russian pelicans glide
along the length of the lake.
The sound of taxis and cyclists
waging war on the [INAUDIBLE],
filters through a
canopy of green needles,
soon to turn cinnamon
orange with autumn.
Unlike most other
conifers, this giant
will drop its leaves
at the end of the year,
living up to its nickname,
the bald cypress.
I descend the spiral in reverse,
returning to planet Earth
like a newborn god.
Exiting the tree's shadow, I try
not to startle the man asleep
on the adjacent bench."
Other trouble with
climbing trees
is that you get an ego
from being above everyone.
So I don't actually think
of myself as a newborn god.
I should clarify.
So some other views of people.
It's Ravenscourt Park, a
cedar tree in West London.
This is a great tree.
This is a horse chestnut in
Temple Gardens on embankment.
And it's actually above the
vent of the London Underground.
So if you climb it,
you have to use that.
It's got a grill,
so you're going
to fall down onto the track.
But if you use it to
climb into the tree,
you can see the district
line trains passing
underneath the branches and
feel the vibration of the steel
through the roots of the trees
and watch people in suits
on their phones, as well.
I've taken lots of snapshots.
If any of you are interested
in seeing more photos of London
from the trees, I have
an Instagram account
called treetop city,
which you can check out.
But yeah, I take lots of
shots of the city itself.
So this is down in Shadwell
in East London, on the Thames.
[INAUDIBLE]
Islington roundabout,
which has an amazing
Californian pine tree where,
again, you can very easily,
without any strength or skill,
get right up above
the Holloway Road.
It is completely
illegal, as well.
But, you know.
So the book is full of
my wife's drawings, who
was heavily pregnant when
I was writing it so refused
to climb any of the trees.
But I was thinking I was going
to read you another extract,
but I think I'll leave
that one for now.
It's a horse chestnut.
In the book, they've
all got nicknames.
That's the nostrils,
for obvious reasons.
I think the other fantastic
thing about sitting in trees
and, you know, whiling
away an hour or two
is the complexity
of the tree itself
that you don't see
from the ground.
So this is the same cedar in
Greenwich Park from above.
And it's a bit like
a roller coaster
trying to climb up into this.
And you'd never see that kind
of architecture of the tree
from below.
There's all kind
of hidden views.
So this is the roots of a
planetree down in the River
Wandle in South London.
This is a tree in
Glasgow, another hornbeam.
There's no filter on this.
These are the lichens
and the moss growing up
in the bowl of the tree.
And climbing up, you suddenly
see this amazing sort
of rainbow universe inside.
It's amazing the
variety of species
planted within the
city limit, as well.
You think of London,
you don't necessarily
think there's going to be a
wealth of different trees.
But within the M25, you get
the most extraordinary trees
from around the world.
This is a chestnut-leaved
oak, from Iran
is where it's native to.
And it's been growing in
London for about 150 years.
But it's a great tree.
I mean, climbing
through this, it's
like sort of doing the limbo
all the way around the tree
because it's got so many
branches hugging the ground.
This is just a common beech tree
down in Richmond Park, which
has being coppiced
back to the ground.
So some of you are probably
much better naturalists than me.
But coppicing is basically
a medieval practice
of cutting wood
from beech and oak
and cutting the branches
right down to the ground,
and then they regrow.
And this one I call
the tree of knowledge
because it looks
so like a snake.
There's a sort of hissing
tongue coming out of the front.
Great place to take a
sandwich and spend a Sunday.
The other thing is
all over London,
because we're such a
crowded city and so dense,
you find trees with
graffiti on them.
When I first started climbing,
I was a bit of a purist,
and I was thinking,
this is a tattoo
that the tree never agreed to.
It's a bit of a
shame that people
are writing their names on it.
But the more you
climb, actually,
especially when you get high up
and find sort of people saying,
I love whoever.
I love God.
God loves me.
It's at 40 foot
above the ground.
They kind of feel a bit like
the living history of the tree.
And bark over time-- this is
another beech, a weeping beach
in Victoria Park.
The bark is obviously
growing, and it
tends to meld the graffiti.
Old graffiti tends to become
almost part of the tree's
own skin.
So it's fun to observe.
I found a lot of
strange things in trees
that people have left there.
Just to give you a short list--
vodka bottles, chicken bones,
balloons, keys, coins,
condoms, flower arrangements,
and a crucifix, which
was very exciting,
wedged in the trunk
of an oak tree.
So the list goes on.
But yeah, there's
all kinds of things
to discover in the branches.
People often ask me what my
tips are for climbing trees.
But as I said at
the beginning, this
is very much an
every man, woman,
and child's amateur book.
So I don't have sage advice.
But a few things I would
say-- climb in bare feet
if you're prepared to.
It's a much more
immersive experience.
You're actually less
likely to slip, especially
if you climb in the
rain in rubber heels.
You're just going to
fall out the tree.
And you're much less likely
to do damage to the tree,
so that's another bonus.
Look out for deadwood.
Nearly every tree
carries deadwood.
So as you go up,
tap the branches.
Make sure you're not
climbing on something
that's got necrosis and is
going to fall under your weight
or fall on someone beneath you.
And remember the way down.
I think when I first started
climbing trees in London,
I got very excited
by what looked
like these very easy
ways to just get
above the city and sort
of 50 foot up without ever
really thinking about how I
was going to get down again.
So I had some really
terrible moments
where I thought, oh, I'm
going to have to call someone
with a ladder, and it's
going to be so embarrassing,
and the publisher's
going to hate it,
and all the rest of it.
So yeah, do always remember
it's much harder to climb down,
for obvious reasons.
You're kind of tired.
And you can actually look
down and see the drop and sort
of blindly feel for footholds.
I think, actually, the best
thing about writing the book
has been the stories
people have shared with me
on the back of it coming out.
So I've had all kinds
of correspondence
from people around
the UK sending
in their tree-climbing stories.
So I had, actually,
only yesterday,
on the back of some
media coverage,
I had a lady write
in her late 80s
to tell me about climbing
her local tree in Oxford
during the Second World War and
pretending it was a Lancaster
bomber while the
Battle of Britain
was raging over the Channel.
It was an amazing story.
Another old guy from
down in Coventry
wrote to me with a story of
climbing elm trees, 25 million
of which were wiped out in the
70s and 80s across England,
but also North America.
So that was a nice
sort of time capsule
because you just can't
climb them anymore.
And not just children's
memories, either,
but adults who've used
tree climbing, sometimes,
as a form of therapy.
So yeah.
I mean, I thought--
I've got a little video
that I'd like to play you.
But what would be
great is if any of you
wanted to share your own
tree-climbing stories
or ask me any
questions, as well.
But let's play the video first.
Actually, this picture here,
just very quickly-- my book's
free.
So you don't have to buy that.
This book you should buy.
This is by an Italian, dead
Italian, called Italo Calvino.
I don't know if any
of you know him.
"Invisible Cities"
with his famous book.
He's a novelist.
And he wrote a book called
"The Baron in the Trees,"
which was an inspiration
for me because it's
set in this mythical Italian
valley when-- at one time,
Europe and Britain would have
been so heavily forested.
The idea of the book
is this kid climbs out
of his dad's palatial
dining room in rebellion
against living the life
of a sort of aristocrat
and disappears into a
tree in the park, age 12.
And he doesn't come
down for 60 years.
So he sort of starts
revolutions in the trees,
makes love in the trees,
just hangs out in trees.
And even when he dies, as
you'll find out in the book,
it doesn't come back to ground.
So wonderful book, Italo
Calvino "Baron in the Trees,"
if you're interested.
So these are some of
the trees from the book.
So, yeah, does anyone
have any questions
or want to know why I got
stopped by the police?
AUDIENCE: What did
the police say?
JACK COOKE: It was-- well, it's
not a funny story, exactly.
But I found it quite funny.
I was climbing in
Brompton Cemetery.
So in the book, there is a
whole chapter on cemeteries.
I must hasten to add I'm not
disrespectful of the dead.
But I do think
climbing in cemeteries
where there aren't
active internments
or where you're not actually
next to graves, recent graves,
is kind of its own
form of tribute
because all the bodies are
in the branches, anyway.
So that's my very
personal take on it.
But yes, I was in
Brompton Cemetery
climbing another pine tree
above Chelsea stadium.
So it goes-- it's a
very tall tree, again.
And I came down.
If anyone knows
Brompton Cemetery,
there's kind of three big
marble arches on the north end.
And I came down.
I'm brushing pine needles out of
my hair and green at the knees.
And this police
car comes screaming
through the front entrance.
And I think, this can't
possibly be for me.
I mean, I was climbing a tree.
I haven't killed
anyone or anything.
And this big, bearded
copper go out.
And he was smiling.
And he said, where
you just up a tree?
And I thought, I'd better
be innocent and honest.
So I said, yes.
Was I not meant to be?
I'm very sorry.
I'm training to
be a tree surgeon.
That was a lie.
And he said, a woman just
rang up the Hammersmith
and Fulham Police Station
to say a young man was
about to commit suicide.
So he thought he
was going to find
me hanging from a
branch, hence the speed
and haste of response,
and hence the big smile
and letting me off
with a warning.
But yeah, I mean, I
think my favorite thing
about sort of this
borderline trespassing
and the ambiguity of
some of these laws
is that, especially in
summer or in evergreens,
you're so hidden from
the city that actually,
no rational-- no one's going
to bother to stop you, really.
I mean, I would say don't
climb ancient or fragile trees.
Don't climb saplings.
But there's plenty-- there's
seven and a half million trees
in this city.
There's plenty to climb.
78 in the book.
There's a lot more to discover.
MALE SPEAKER: Anyone
got any other questions?
JACK COOKE: Or stories
about climbing trees?
I'm not.
I mean, I think what
I try and lay out
in the first
chapters of the book
is this is to encourage
people to climb trees again
and to use these as
a kind of platform
to go and find their own.
I would say that I
think any damage done
to any of these trees,
the experience of getting
into a tree and that
visceral having to hold on
and actually pay attention--
because I find in my life,
and in my last job
particularly, I
go through a whole
day of routine
without really paying
attention to anything.
Climbing into a
tree was suddenly
this focus on everything.
And I think the value of that,
both to children and adults,
outweighs any damage done.
So I think if you asked, like--
if you went to Kew Gardens,
where you shouldn't climb
trees-- they're in the book--
and asked some of
the botanists there
or the tree surgeons what got
them into tree conservation,
I think a lot of them
would say climbing trees.
So it's not-- I think the value
of that is more important.
MALE SPEAKER: Could you
repeat the question, as well?
JACK COOKE: Oh, yes.
How did I get into
climbing trees?
So I worked in an office
next to Regent's Park.
And it was this
tiny little attic
on the fourth floor
that had-- it should
have had an amazing
view over the park,
but it had a massive
concrete wall built
across the windows,
which apparently was
to hide the servants from the
high society of the day that
built the building.
Anyway, one day the whole
office flooded during a storm
in summertime.
And the caretaker came in
and opened up the skylights
onto the roof.
And I went out onto the roof.
And I was reading this
book, "Baron in the Trees,"
circumstantially at the time.
I looked out across
the park and thought,
I've got to take a sandwich
and go and climb a tree.
So I went down to the park,
found a very easy tree,
climbed up.
And I was probably 30 feet
up this tree or something.
And between the leaves
and the branches,
this view opened out of
the BT Tower and Warren
street and all the
hospital blocks,
just kind of perfectly
framed in the view.
And I thought, I
really want to share
these views and this
experience and this space
because London is
overcrowded, but I just
felt this is sort
of virgin territory.
So yeah.
And then I became
addicted and quit my job.
Probably a mistake in
the long run, but hey.
Yeah.
I'm doing, I think I'm
booked in to do one
at Wilderness Festival.
I don't know if any of you
know Wilderness Festival.
I've never been,
but wonderful trees.
I'd certainly love to.
I think I'd probably have to get
all kinds of waivers for people
to sign so if they
fell out, [INAUDIBLE].
But yeah, I mean, there
are some really nice trees.
I was doing-- there's a fun
little video on the Londonist,
if any of you subscribe
to that, of me
climbing a tree in Clissold
Park, sort of Stoke Newington
area.
And that's the kind of tree
you could get 20 people
into on these low branches.
And it'd be a really
fun one for a tree tour.
So yeah, I'd definitely
be up for doing that.
Yeah.
It'd be fun.
I mean, you know, if you're
a parkour expert or a rock
climber and you can do multiple
pull-ups on your little
fingers, then obviously, you're
going to be great at climbing
trees.
I'm neither of those things.
But I think the
appeal to me of trees
is that almost anyone
can do it, and you
don't need that enormous
upper body strength of things.
I've had some sort of
contact from parkour.
People have been like, yeah!
Can we use this tree to get
from this rooftop to this one?
And I think, maybe.
You can.
But no, I mean,
there's some sort
of movements now of people.
There's one guy from Hampstead
Heath who kind of runs
these workshops where he-- I
think they're called Evolve,
Move, Play or something.
And that group,
they're very athletic.
And they're very good at sort
of swinging between branches
and all that kind of thing.
Me, I like to just sort of
take it slow and basically idle
around in trees.
AUDIENCE: Do you find
it quite meditative?
JACK COOKE: Very, yeah.
Again, someone said
to me whether the book
was all about mindfulness.
I'd never really heard
this expression before,
so I had to look it up.
But it kind of is
because it's-- again,
the space to reflect and just
take time out from your day is
unparalleled.
I mean, maybe
someone can tell me,
but I don't know
another place in London
where I feel that opportunity.
So yeah, definitely.
That's a key thing
about it for me.
Yeah.
Like an app?
Again, I say actually
just climbing
a tree is so much better than
a textbook in that I climbed
a lot of trees in ignorance.
But because I was
writing the book,
I bought-- this is like
a plug for my publisher--
but the "Collins
Tree Guide," which
is a little handheld book.
And just going back to the
same trees again and again
and looking them up-- and a lot
of the trees in the book, when
I was writing it, I still
wasn't sure what species it was.
So I was constantly
trying to find out.
But I think there's some--
especially if you climb trees
in winter or deciduous
trees when they haven't got
their leaves, there's
so many ways to tell
that it's that tree when
you're up in the branches.
You can look at buds that
stay on the tree over winter,
different-- the bark
itself, as well.
So this is not a short answer
or particularly helpful.
I think just immersion in it.
The more you climb trees,
the more interested
you are in finding
out about them.
So those textbooks
that might seem
very dry to begin with actually
became really exciting to me
because I was like, oh,
it's that tree that's
against St. Paul's Cathedral
that I nearly fell out of
is actually a sweet gum tree.
Who knew?
So I think that was
the process for me.
But yeah, no easy
answer, I'm afraid.
And I've got a long
way to go, as well.
I'm still learning.
For me?
I think my wife might leave
me if I keep climbing trees.
Every holiday we've
been on, I kind of
force her to stop the car on
every roadside and climb trees.
It's such an obsession.
So no.
I think I would love
to write another book,
but it won't be about trees
directly, I don't think.
MALE SPEAKER: Well, if
there's no more questions,
you're gonna stay around
and sign some books?
JACK COOKE: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: So
thank you very much.
JACK COOKE: Thanks
for having me.
[APPLAUSE]